he's reading the Bible his wife is
desperately ill they've been here for a
month in truth divine intervention is
the best they can hope for
because in Venezuelan hospitals today
there is no medicine to speak of in fact
there's nothing
this is one of the country's biggest
hospitals just capacity for 1200 people
they're looking after just 170 and
looking after them is literal they
aren't being treated there is nothing at
all
they spend days and weeks just lying
here staff broke all the rules to bring
us into the hospital to film undercover
we had to keep moving to avoid
government guards this lady told me
she's been looking after her mother here
for three months she keeps getting
infections and is getting weaker she and
her family have to provide all the food
and water incredibly they came here
because the hospital where they live is
actually worse
the toilets are unusable they're filthy
and there's no water
it's as far away from you describing
that medical facility as it's possible
to imagine
fell announces that running water here
at all
if anything I meet you before this
actually hold apartments of the hospital
have completely shut down wards are
abandoned in some there are just rows of
empty beds were exhausted family members
try to get some rest
the old and the young societies we curse
are here there is no medicine to treat
them though this mum told us she'd been
asked to go out and find medicine for
the staff to treat her daughter it's a
shopping list not a prescription
just this emergency medicine will cost
80,000 bolivars the monthly wage here is
18,000 it's hopelessly difficult for her
I have to bring water because there
isn't any I take my girl to the bathroom
but she just can't go because it's not
working
she's 6 years old how do I tell her she
can't go to the toilets the lack of
medicine is quite astounding because
even a couple of years ago when I was
last here there was some
this is meant to have obviously you
expect to see of dangly emergency
supplies drugs because is etcetera in
the work station is completely bare but
here is just empty
two bottles down there
because it's just not working but this
is what the opposition wants to
highlight to the people of Venezuela and
with a promise that they will bring
about change here with international
help and in the short term bring in
medical aid that is threatening to
become a clash between the government
and the opposition with the United
States watching on in the meantime these
people spend another day in bed hoping
things will get better
still Ramzi Sky News Caracas